- Speaking of his fans though,
this happened recently at one
of Matt's shows, watch this.
- [Audience Member] And she
had wanted you to figure out-
- Oh! (beep)
- [Audience Member] The original way.
- Yo, can we get a paramedic
real quick, paramedic please.
You okay?
[Audience Member 2] Oh, she's gonna cry.
- [Matt] Are you all right?
You feeling okay, you promise?
- [Audience Member 3] Can
I get a picture with you?
- Yeah, of course,
just don't use it for
the obituary, my God.
(audience cheering)
- The best line, what happened?
- Well, she's okay, she's fine.
- Which is why the joke is funny.
- Oh, of course, of course.
No, we wouldn't have continued the show
if some tragic (beep) happened.
Like, somebody get her outta
here, I gotta plug merch.
(audience laughing)
Cut, cut, rewind it.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- This was probably 25 minutes
into one of our headlining shows.
And I hear this commotion
and I look down and I
could see she's convulsing.
So I immediately, once I
recognized what was happening,
I called for anybody being
a paramedic in the room
and luckily the people at the venue,
and people who do work
in the medical field
that were in the audience
rush to her side immediately.
I have to leave the
stage when that happens,
so that I can be informed
as to what's going on
while she's getting tended to properly.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And not in anybody's way.
And it was like seven
or eight minutes later,
I would say, my security
came back and was like,
hey, she wants to stay.
And I was like, I'll give her a refund.
Like she doesn't have to stay.
But she, I went out there and I was like,
lemme just go talk to her,
make sure she's all right.
And I walked out
and the first thing I said
was like, are you okay?
She was like, yeah, can I have a picture?
I was like, yeah, no flash.
She had epilepsy, what a
wild thing to ask first, man.
But you gotta respect
the passion, you know?
She wanted to stay.
She had to, you know, carpe diem.
- But the thing is comedy
makes people happy.
- [Matt] Oh, of course.
- You make people happy,
you make people laugh.
I forgot this,
and I went to a show here
recently in New York,
and it made me feel so good
to get out and just laugh.
- [Al] With other people.
- Yes.
- Oh, absolutely, you have no idea.
It brings people together
to such an extreme level.
You think it's just random jokes
that you're just telling
to make people happy.
- [Kelly] No we're all
connecting in a different way.
- Yeah, absolutely,
she was such a good
sport about everything.